sin sentido
[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión
de los observadores en france24
blanco como siempre un gusto
acompañarlos esta semana comenzamos en
abiyán en costa de márfil nuestro
observador alertó sobre un problema en
un barrio de esta ciudad
desde hace varios meses los residentes
se quejan de una nube de polvo que cubre
un barrio en kate vil en abiyán está
cerca de las fábricas de cemento nuestro
observador a la maqueta fue hasta el
lugar para hablar con los recientes
sobre esta problemática del ser yo
vinimos sobre el terreno estamos con
nuestro hermano que nos hablará más
explicaciones ya no podemos quedarnos
afuera del cimiento cubre todo el barrio
no podemos ni respirar así que le
pedimos que nos ayude con este problema
porque no podemos soportarlo más
el polvo se ve en la ropa se ve en la
piel de los habitantes del barrio
es polvo está en todas partes por todas
partes en los autos en los árboles y
donde se lo imaginen hay polvo sorpresa
sólo dos semanas un amigo mío me llamó
un sábado que había llegado una nube de
polvo de cemento a la zona como si fuera
a llover
los habitantes del barrio están
preocupados simplemente porque su
calidad de vida se está viendo
severamente repito severamente afectada
y son conscientes de que esto puede
tener naturalmente consecuencias para su
salud el problema no es nuevo en este
barrio desde 2015 los informes
medioambientales han demostrado que el
nivel de partículas finas eran hasta
cuatro veces superior a la norma
establecida por la oms la causa es el
polvo de clínker un material utilizado
en la fabricación de cemento según el
ministerio de medio ambiente con el que
nos pusimos en contacto la situación
está relacionada con un conjunto de
factores que van desde la descarga de
mercancías en el puerto pasando por el
aumento de la actividad de transporte de
clínker en camiones a principios de 2021
varios habitantes de treichville
señalaron a las cementeras y me voy
situada en el barrio desde 2018 como
responsable de la contaminación ésta
organizó una jornada de puertas abiertas
para intentar tranquilizar a la
población una iniciativa que nuestro
observador considera que es positiva
pero para él es necesario ir más allá
demostraron su buena voluntad y fueron
realmente profesionales y cada quien se
formó una opinión las respuestas dadas
por las partes involucradas no son en
absoluto satisfactorias podría hasta
pensarse que nadie es responsable de
esta contaminación una vez del cielo
estamos viendo un partido de ping pong
donde no hay culpables
los habitantes de recibir esperan aquí y
ahora que el estado de costa de marfil
obligue a todas esas empresas implicadas
en esta contaminación a respetar el
pliego de condiciones que nosotros
también podamos vivir en un ambiente
sano y de altea
las fábricas de cemento presentes en la
zona así como el director del puerto de
abiyán aseguraron que un nuevo sistema
de aspiración de partículas finas en
mayo podría mejorar la calidad de vida
de los habitantes de ese sector vamos a
estar en contacto para ver si este tema
ha mejorado
en tick tock se pueden encontrar vídeos
muy divertidos pero también unos mucho
más serios como este de un campo de
refugiados sirios llamé el vélez hay
aquí en nuestro equipo de reacción nos
cuenta más
[Música]
sí
y este no es el tipo de vídeo que se
suele ver en youtube estos niños viven
en un campo de desplazados internos sus
familias huyeron de los combates entre
el régimen sirio los grupos rebeldes
casi 1.400.000 personas viven en
campamentos como este en el norte de
siria algunos de ellos llevan viviendo
allí desde el comienzo del conflicto
hace 10 años
[Música]
así que para dar a conocer la vida de
estos olvidados de la guerra un
activista sirio decidió filmar los y
publicados vídeos en default
la aplicación dicto que se ha convertido
en una de las más populares del mundo es
una forma muy eficaz de difundir vídeos
debemos utilizar todos los medios
posibles para informar sobre las
condiciones de vida del pueblo sirio
muchos desplazados cuando se dieron
cuenta de que iban a estar en los
campamentos durante mucho tiempo
empezaron a construir casas con piedras
que encontraban en el campo
con un salario
solo construyen paredes y un techo
rudimentario con un trozo del 11 para
mejorar un poco la vida cotidiana de sus
familias
porque está durmiendo ahí porque hace
mucho calor no puede dormir adentro lo
deja frente a la puerta del baño es la
única opción que tenemos encontré que en
muchos campamentos como el déjala blavet
que firme el sistema de evacuación de
aguas negras no es suficiente para todos
los habitantes de la gente tiene cada
vez una zanja al lado de la tienda de
campaña y luego recoger esta agua en un
cubo y votarla un poco lejos del
campamento últimamente ha habido muchos
incendios por desgracias
por eso una ong local ha organizado
clases para que los desplazados estén
preparados para apagar un incendio
rápidamente
hay muchos campamentos las tiendas de
campaña se han convertido en aguas ya
que hay pocas escuelas y muchos niños en
estos campamentos se llama en estas
escuelas btu no hay sillas ni tableros
por los profesores y dan clases
gratuitas
[Música]
el vamos
y de esta manera llegamos al final de
nuestro programa por esta semana
recuerde que todos nuestros contactos
aparecen en pantalla donde esperamos sus
fotos y videos aficionados para contar
la historia del lado de la gente
[Música]